il
dans dix ans
ou pas
c'est
ça t'amuse festival de cannes
ouais j'aime bien ça je trouve que les
soupes du cinéma c'est dire c'est
formidable à quel point on arrive à
faire du cinéma à cannes sans matériel
juste comme ça en causant à table c'est
bien mais ça te plaît comme ça 50
interview par jour oh non ça c'est
évidemment ça me fameux
ça me gonfle un peu ça c'est souvent
parce que ça fait chier de s'expliquer
si les gens en général fini vont devoir
et puis c'est tout c'est pas à
m'expliquer je suis du cinéma je fais
pas tu te vois en vieux acteurs quand il
vieillira quoi tu ressembles il ya les
vieux du cinéma ya pas seulement comment
jamais dit on change de vue c'est à dire
noah vieux c'est pas vrai c'est pas la
saisie un vieux partir du moment où on a
peur d'eux
on accorde du lendemain c'est à ce
moment là comme dit un jeu
j'ai perdu ma mère je suis ça de ne
jamais avoir peur de l'homme comme ta
tête trouve beau mais si tu dis un show
je suis déjà chaud je trouve beau style
plaît abri très bien je trouve que ça me
donne un certain charme
est ce qu'il ya des acteurs qui
t'intéresse à part toi bien sûr
c'est mes rêves d'enfant c'est dur c'est
dans l'ombre en dos et dustin hoffman
c'est jane fonda c'est shelley duvall
comme on tourne deux jours ou trois
semaines avant le palmarès de cas des
petits rêves comme ça deux grands prix
d'interprétation tu t'en fous
complètement
moi je veux de toute façon j'ai toujours
raté tous les examens je suis très très
très habitué j'ai jamais été choisie par
un jury jamais moi alors oui alors cela
dit j'ai envie d'avoir interprète après
après l'interprétation parce que je suis
français et que je représente la france
alors vive la france ce pronostic
c'est retour aux vieilles photos du tout
c'est vrai que c'est ce que je pense
parce que je pense je veux dire le prix
d'interprétation d'une façon moi je sais
ce que je suis je veux dire c'est pas
parce qu'on vient de décerner un truc
mais les gens savent ce que je suis je
voulais les spectateurs aussi qu'ils
sont right is yen alors à partir du
moment où ils viennent et où ça
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
l'interprétation
face donc j'avais beaucoup plus loin en
tout cas j'espère et je crois pas le
public pour des cons ça les fera pas ça
me fera pas perdre un pouce ni en
gagnant parce qu'un prix
d'interprétation chez les gens ils ont
jugé comme un jury est-ce que tu
commandes qu'il puisse exaspérer aussi
des chants par ta manière de jouer
tellement violent tellement comme sa
bouillonnante
enfin ce qui ravit complètement françois
chalais même pas les acteurs sobre
insufficient moi j'aime bien j'aimerais
bien mais j'ai l'impression je suis
sobre
voilà ça a été de ça au maximum pour ça
je vous dis j'essaie d'en faire un
minimum mais je pense peut être que
c'est pas mal mon tempérament
j'aimerais bien jouer comme d'armement
donc fait rien et est fou mais
j'aimerais bien jouer avec dustin
hoffman aussi qu'en fait beaucoup et et
qui est vraiment tellement vrai alors je
sais pas je crois je pense que je dois
faire je fais toujours au mieux
une question
pourquoi tu attends de diamant sur toi
je trouve ça beau c'est vrai nom soit
c'est du strass et l'oreille ça c'est le
diamant pourquoi les diamants dans la
peau parce que hier à sète en smoking
alors l'or ça va pas